[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the show everybody welcome to
the show uh my name is Greg Ivory we're
going to get straight to it guys let's
get straight to it straight to the nitty
gritty we are here for a reason we're
here to build a parlay with you guys and
we're doing no playing but like I said
my name is Greg Ivory next to me is the
man I like to call MB known as Michael
Bolin and next to him is the men on the
show we like to call producer Ryan he is
the one that gels us to you guys uh last
week last week we built our five leg
parlay
and did it hit Ryan
uh it did not Austin Reeves sold uh and
now he joins Clay Thompson on our banned
list uh for those who don't know what a
ban list is it means we're never ever
ever touching you again
you're not Oscar Reeves is on the ban
list we went six legs last week we were
feeling good we went six legs hit five
Austin Reeves did not show up but guess
what we're here today running it back so
drop your best locks for tonight in the
chat and we'll cook them into a parlay
Ryan what does the chat like tonight uh
well B thompson88 came in here and said
uh I want big odds but winnable plays
isn't that the goal for everything don't
we all brother don't we all
one of us one of us
then he also came in and said uh he
thinks that jokic uh the joker I'm not
gonna try it we're starting off we're
starting off hot jokic uh we'll have
more than eight assists tonight
oh okay okay interesting
we'll start out in the late game we'll
start out in the late game
Greg you're usually the numbers guys so
you want to pull up what his uh assist
numbers have looked like recently
because it's interesting that we would
start with listen Joker's been playing
at an MVP level yet again nobody should
be surprised I think the eight assists
is probably interesting number
his name is
I'm sorry didn't mean to interrupt but
you could talk about assists let's talk
about assist with yogurt I mean jokic
here we go
Genesis
well first off Ryan I got I got caught
up saying Joker and jokic I know how to
say jokish okay here we go here we go
with the assistant all right we're going
ten eight eight fourteen nine eight nine
eight twelve eight do I keep should I
like keep going okay so then I'll put it
in wait wait wait put it in do we do so
then here's my uh this is this is just
what I do I didn't hear a number below
eight in that do we just do eight plus
yes all right cool yes all right cool
cool cool cool cool wait what's this
what's this
was it eight and a half it was eight and
a half
do we not want to do six plus
oh
oh
interesting for me you usually narrative
for the regular line continues to change
week two weeks I'm just trying to win
like hey let's see let's start with
eight start with eight and see what else
freaking all right
all right I like that I like it good
move
um
do we want to stick to this game also
I'm seeing uh Wizards plus seven just to
reiterate here only the TNT games
because then it's no sweat for us if you
bet I think it's like 25 25 plus dollars
and we lose we get the money back at our
free bet so we're gonna stick to the TNT
games here
um let's see let's see let's see let's
see hey somebody said elaire said y'all
not even gonna look at the grizzly
Center defense just gonna put it in
we're talking about yo kids bro like
against everybody like the match-up kind
of doesn't really matter in the
situation and who is it Stephen Adams
like I'm not worried about Steven Adams
on the Joker not at all yeah uh hey all
right we could go we could jump to the
other game because I'm seeing a lot of
Julius Randle I see Randall in the
comments too bro in the comments yeah
and then I see e-daddy with Draymond
over 21 and a half points rebounds
assist so let's go over to
let's go over to that other game
so the two games
I don't want to touch Draymond oh all
right
no Steph I don't want to touch Draymond
Draymond had a pretty good offensive
game recently right
did he oh yeah he did but I think
somebody I know had him like under
points or something he went over which
is like rare for him but
either way I mean like without stuff
it's kind of spooky these days Greg can
say it
yeah facts so what are you looking at
Ryan Julius Randle over 24 and a half
yeah but the number I got in the chat
was 21 and a half so I I already don't
like that I'm jumping in here and it's
it's off so but you know what to do
though yeah we might go to 20.
all right let's see
minus 400 what does this do for us minus
one okay all right so we said we're
gonna get five legs so we're trending in
the right direction we're training right
we're training all right uh we had Clee
also drop in uh Jordan Poole over four
assists
this was a lady before yeah we've done
this before yeah easy money and he was a
starter yeah the number's at five and a
half so let's buy it down to four I love
this
we're at plus all right now we're in
plus money territory but these are three
legs that we're all really confident in
the really confident on the chat is
doing their job tonight that's that's
right yeah
um the chat is doing their job we're
doing our job guys I love the way we're
monitoring these and going to these you
know uh these these four plus twenty
plus and we're and we're we're we're
milking it that way but uh the chat is
talking about draymond's draymond's
rebound total
all right yeah
gotta read on it but they're talking
about his rebound total okay uh I what I
just real quick let's review what we
have so far it's Julius Randle 20 plus
points Jordan pool four plus assists and
then jokic
eight plus assists would you guys like
the price I like what we've started
that's good pronunciation for producer
Ryan thank you
so my argument for
Draymond rebounds is I saw the Knicks
playing person against the Bulls last
week
and they miss a lot of shots they take a
lot of early possession shots so the
opportunity could be there to have a
bunch of rebounds
the problem I have on the other side is
Will Draymond play underneath if he's
guarding Julius Randle he's going to be
running around the three-point line kind
of a lot
yep that's a good point and beat but
yeah they also go small ball uh-huh
that's true Dre you know kicks into that
five
so if Dre plays the five then they have
you know you could put what I saw was
they had Caruso switching on to
Julius Randle whenever they got a switch
so maybe they'll do the same thing I
mean six rebounds doesn't seem like a
lot
uh
we could put a pin on it I'm not like
like sold on that like I don't know if
you guys are I'm not sold on that let's
we can put a pin on it a pin in it but I
I saw something that was very
interesting I saw John Moran
over 20.5
we're also getting some Jordan pool just
so while we're on this game right now
it's just if we want to talk about it
Jordan pool 25 plus is that I think we
need here's the deal I think we need
like one really confident plus money
play right now yep so I'm down to go
over to the other game Greg and we'll
we'll go
we'll go to the Grizzlies and the
nuggets
which Vegas is expecting this game to be
not only high scoring but also very
close so points bro the Grizzlies
against the nuggets
Grizzlies
thinking about anyway adding the
Grizzlies to the parlay the Grizzlies
that Brian is it isn't it plus money
are they plus I didn't think they were
no minus 104
I don't hate it close to it I mean I
like it we let's ask them let's ask the
audience though
it took our parlay to plus 333 we're
we're trending
we are trying we don't have to go too
crazy obviously we're the next two plays
are big though the next two legs are big
yeah this is a week this will be what
decides it for sure next next two are
big if you guys like the Memphis
Grizzlies moneyline play uh we need
thumbs up in the comments thumbs down if
you guys don't like it but Ryan John
Morant
I I'm just looking in in the comments
and I see a lot of people talking about
them we we went 28.5
I don't know yeah this is tough this is
tough right now because like right now
we're just getting straight
like minus 110 minus 118 plays yeah I
feel like the way to to go about this is
we're getting mixed signals on the
thumbs up thumbs down here with the
Grizzlies I feel like the way to go
about this is three pointers I feel like
that's usually where I feel the most
confident in terms of plus money
following you well we did we did once
take Jalen Brunson over 1-3 as a leg
that was the that was the parlay we won
yes but I watched him knock down a bunch
of shots and we don't have to jump back
and forth but I agree that I think that
the the three-point props are definitely
where to go especially I got a question
guys close to even money or Plus what's
that I got a question I got a question
we all agree that this is going to be a
high scoring game right or wrong go to
the line Ryan
even the audience is talking about it
they they're giving us thumb down about
the Grizzlies money line but they said
over under might be something to look at
but two if it's going to 37 if it's
going to be a high scoring game don't we
know that job marant is gonna score
definitely
Ryan have we ever have we ever took a
alternate point total I like where
you're I like where you're going with
this I'm saying we saying 30 plus 30
plus
juicy
I wish that would have done a little
more for us yeah that's that was a sigh
of disappointment
I wish it would have done a little bit
more but it's a it's a plus money play
um
I have a play from one of our
Community captains
Julius Randle over threes is Plus 100. I
watched him shoot five threes in the
first quarter and he made three of them
we also had him in a parlay where we
needed him to make two and he definitely
made two like right away
so maybe instead of taking Randall's
points maybe we do the threes because
apparently it's plus 100 shots of bad
boy
but it don't don't you think they kind
of go hand in hand in in a way obviously
he's not going to get if he hits more
than two threes he's not gonna get 20
points that's not a guarantee but I feel
like we're almost by doubling up on
Julius
I feel like I'm comfortable doubling up
in that way it's kind of what I'm saying
yeah no I I I'm my point was instead of
Randall points
locking in the threes prop because it's
better value
okay if we're trying to move the value
now I this is obviously not our parlay
it's the community's parlays so it might
be worth looking guys yes sir guys B
Thompson who who's all of a a loyal fan
of the show I mean if you taking Jai at
30 plus you might as well take jokic at
nine alternate rebounds
now I'm not saying we have to do it I
just I'm
this is the people's parlay and I'm just
one of the and put their uh input I
guess I don't hate that he had like 27
rebounds the other day and Vegas Vegas
is expecting a lot of points so
it's gonna be a lot of shots taken
nine rebounds for yokich doesn't seem
like ridiculous his number is ten and a
half he also is questionable in this
game so I don't know
like even if he does play I'm not sure
and then that makes me question the
assists wow
let me check out while you while you go
through the chat I'm gonna check on my
sources on his injury we'll see what's
up all right hey Ryan
yes sir I I see a Jordan pool two threes
yeah I'm I like that I feel a lot better
about this other game I'm not gonna lie
about this this next Warriors game yeah
player threes
oh man
three and a half expecting a lot of
we're expecting a lot of Jordan pool
tonight what's what's uh you know you
know what we do go to the two plus and
see what that what that does for us
oh no never mind
I mean I mean we could add it just as
like a throw-in leg but I don't know I
don't know what do you think about three
threes
we can't do three flat we can either
only do two oh wait nope I'm a liar
that's yep that's on me
the
Mouse Moving
yeah so then and then we can no and and
then what we what we can do is what you
said before which is let's we could take
out Julius Randle
and see what his threes are for two
for Two Plus yeah
it's about the same
this is tough
we are in a pickle
yeah this is difficult
[Music]
um is there anyone else's threes that we
like here the Jalen Brunson
joyous Randalls at at two and a half
RJ Barrett seems to have the most value
if we want someone in this game for
threes because it's two and a half
to plus money so I'm assuming two threes
will probably be close to even
minus 210 that gets us to where we feel
comfortable though in terms of like that
place yeah that's five plays plus five
thirty five
how many does he have to make two two
yeah it was two so so our legs that we
have are jokic uh eight plus assists
marant 30 plus points
Jordan pool four plus assists Jordan
pool three plus made threes and RJ
Barrett two plus made threes okay so I'm
looking at RJ Barrett his last five
two threes four threes three threes but
the big one very much recently
oh for five so is he do or is he cold
it's a great question that is a great
question Michael Bolin just never know
I do think this game probably sets up
nicely for him I think the way he played
against the Bulls probably gives me a
better better signal I mean this game
hey guys for five from three but he was
10 for 19 from the field so he played
well hey but we were just talking about
this guy before the show Quentin Grimes
it's right there below him better odds
wow that's funny you say that because
the chat is really interested in that
Quentin Grimes you're just a man of the
people Greg and that's why we love you
we gotta connect with the people guys we
gotta connect with the people so we're
just talking about quick Grimes yep
Wayne 60 said he doesn't trust RJ
locks underwater shout out to Locks
underwater he said he's cold so let's
swap out let's swap out RJ for Quentin
Grimes all right oh that got just a
pretty yeah yeah that looks pretty I'm
seeing Brunson two plus threes and I'm
trying to figure out if there's a leg
here that we're just not cool with
so I'm definitely in on jokic uh assist
I think that's a lot as long as he
finishes the game which all the reports
that I quickly read said he was probable
I'm not a right
my bad MB you want you want my honest
opinion that pull three threes scares
you
I'm skeptical
okay
yeah out of everything that we have
that's the one that I'm like oh
yeah and that is what are the odds on
that that
is minus 390. so we can find something
that we feel a little bit better at uh
better better with so
let's look in the audience I mean let's
look in the chat uh uh everybody's keep
talking about Brunson but Jalen Brunson
two plus threes is what I'm seeing
I mean Jalen Brunson Jalen Bronson
you know who's been balling Dante
divincenzo
way way I saw a report that he might be
sick with covet so let's oh I saw that I
saw that never mind never mind okay I
don't know if it's official or not but I
know somebody's out and he was like also
kind of sick so just let's make sure
yeah he's not he's not in here to take
anyway so you're right Envy eight
what about Mariah
I did not see this in the chat and I'm
sorry Chad I usually am a man of the
people
but what about
kaminga
points the Greg lag returns
The
Rook has been balling I don't think why
am I not able to I guess he's not an
option here
because they know he's gonna ball yeah
they saw what we did last week
they know the shows tonight they're on
to us
this is interesting I'm seeing a lot of
interesting comments and they are
talking about Jordan Poole which it
seems positive as a as a Michigan fan
and a fan of his just overall that kid
loves the big Spotlight Planet MSG
I think he might have a big night I
think having two legs of his in here
probably is too much so we gotta pick
which one we think we like the best but
I think he's definitely gonna have a
good game
I'm more skeptical about him passing the
ball than I am him chucking up threes
that's just my take on that hey B B
Thompson says
hey they also says incomingo we trust I
just want you guys to know hell yeah
are you seeing the uh you're seeing the
the bones Highland love yes yes the
bones Island you saw that I love me some
bones I love it it's such a stud yeah
not the TV show The the
guy from the Nuggets bones
TV show not that great yeah the rerun
show yeah sorry if we have some bones
fence in here
uh you probably shouldn't talk about the
bone show anymore because it's pretty
close to
our company's heart anyway moving on
[Laughter]
um come on I want to bet I want to bet
on Bones that's
how do they not oh man that's tough that
means that word we've got two plays here
super sharp but like we can't fight dang
it
uh they said my boy caminga isn't
playing uh all right no man I wanted
bones clear 15 saying pull threes three
threes is the play not a CIS okay yeah
that's that's kind of what I was saying
before is like go ahead and read all
Jordan read 24 also agrees pool is going
off in Madison Square man so
I mean I like it man what we can do is
we could take out his assist and we can
just pair up
uh 25 plus or like we can go over to his
points and pair it up with the threes
you know if we're really if we're saying
this is gonna be a Jordan pool kind of
night then we can go down here
and do this and see what that does do
that just do that or we can go to 20.
yeah or we can go to 20 points and let's
see what that what that does for us
no not enough not enough for me no no
that's 476. well well
it's only not enough if we feel like
we're locking this in because we could
put 20 and then make one more
one more move but we do like I mean I do
like what we got right now I'm not sure
we need to pair them up because it would
suck for pool to make three of seven
threes and then finish with 22 points
yeah right I don't like the threes guys
I don't like the threes
yeah the chat is all over the threes
okay okay I I I I gotta hey the chat's
the chat the chat this is their parlay
hands are up so what I do Greg when I
feel strongly about something like this
is I take a clip from this show so when
it loses I post it so everyone knows
everyone knows I didn't support this
guy though
that's what I was told no not a receipts
guy not a receipts guy not an I Told You
So guy just an insurance what about the
player combo Brian
we're looking for plus money the uh
somebody in the comments just said
Jordan pulls player combo but we don't
really look at that
yeah can we add that uh player I don't
know if this is you're able to same game
now you're not you're not able to same
game parlay it unfortunately no same
game okay now
so I I'm cool with oh man this is tough
because like
we're getting a lot of Brunson threes
love too yeah we talked about that I've
seen a lot
I don't know what do we think
I'm cool with this but I also like plus
4.95 isn't necessarily for five legs is
it what you love to see but Ryan all
right let's just get it let's just get a
ball in the bucket yes just get a ball
in the bucket and then you're right
you're right
five to one
yeah I I like it so let's let's go
through it Jordan pool three plus threes
Quentin Grimes two plus threes Jordan
pool 20 plus points
jokic eight plus assists
and John Morant 30 plus points the job
about to go off
child's going off
is that what we're locking in Ryan how
you feeling nervous I won't lie I'm
nervous
what makes you nervous though
I I'm just
I don't know I don't know I couldn't
tell you
um if anything if anything I'm nervous
about 30 points but I know that Jack can
get it is
that's the least what I'm worried about
bro Jah again who's going to guard them
Jamal Murray
jokic no no you're right I'm I'm not
worried about that at all pull threes
concerns me but the people is riding so
I'm rocking with it I do think he's
gonna be dishing that ball around today
though
Jordan pool
but so morant's last five he only played
16 in the last game he has six six
points we had 25 15 26 and then 33
against the Pistons
you're right they can't guard them
that's for sure we don't have much time
left but the only the only thing that
scares me is the jokic uh assists but I
I think I yeah I don't know Ryan we just
went through his numbers do I need to
save him again I I know I know we went
through his numbers I just like I'm
always wary of taking a guy off of like
a historic game
you know what I mean like what was it 40
points 27 rebounds 10 assists like if he
were to waltz in tonight and drop like
eight six and two I know it's not gonna
happen all right he can't do that that
he won't hey Ryan you gotta read the
game the over unders at what almost 240
it's at almost 240 for a reason there's
going to be a lot of buckets gonna be a
lot of points I need up and down talk me
talk me into it you know what I'm saying
a lot of up and down a lot of jokic ball
in his hands finding the open guy yeah
eight assists is a layup baby Thompson
88 B Thompson 98 says he might have
eight assists in the first half
I mean that's the confidence that I need
he literally hasn't with under eight
assists in the last 10 games it the it
might be longer but the stat sheet that
I'm looking at only goes back two games
yeah yeah I'm I'm all right I'm cool
with it I just like oh okay is the chat
okay with this dropping down to Plus
482.
well we gotta go yeah yeah I know so
thumbs up or thumbs down if you like the
parlay quickly
two plus uh two plus made threes Jordan
pool 20 plus points John Morant 30 plus
points and jokic eight plus assists
you guys let us know if you guys like it
thumbs up in the chat if you guys do not
like it thumbs down Ryan
your face bro you're nervous I need Good
Vibes I know I know I can tell I can I
can feel it I could feel Vibes I I just
want to win I want to win so bad it's
been a while look at the chat we're
getting Thumbs Up Guys and we're getting
thumbs up we're getting some no's we're
getting some thumbs down
this is size 50 50.
it's 50 50. Ryan I don't know what it
would replace yeah I don't know what we
would replace we got to put our foot
down and stand for something yeah
there's no higher Court we can go to
today unfortunately uh switch pool from
20 to 25 plus
if we were to make a later dish if if
that would be the late switch that we
made how do we'd feel about it yes or no
he said he said get your value
let's do it what it looks like all right
all right all right we'll go quickly
we'll go quickly
this is just like I feel like we're up
against the gun
we're switching and it's gonna be funny
yeah that
um yeah let's do it let's do it this is
what we're doing all right okay this is
yes this is final Jordan pool 25 let's
go up let's go up all right now I'm okay
well now I'm nervous now Jordan pool
three plus made threes Quentin Grimes
two plus made threes Jordan pool 25 plus
points
jokic eight plus assists and John Morant
30 plus points those are five legs that
add up to plus 637
I like this guys let's go guys let's go
I'm nervous my energy today
Ryan's giving us nervous energy and that
is okay a lot of gvos
if you switched it from 30 to 25 for a
job what does it do quickly
we don't have to show it you just tell
us all right all right all right
no he's getting 30.
I do yeah yeah if anything bro take out
Jordan pool making three threes I I
don't think he's gonna
a warrior fan I don't know if he's gonna
do that no I dropped it before no no
we're leaving it that's a no-go that's a
no-go 637 we're good all right all right
all right all right we're locked in Ryan
we're locked in we're locked in give it
to him one more time seems to be
positive about it as well all right last
time here here we go we've got uh Jordan
pool three plus made threes Quentin
Grimes two plus made threes Jordan pull
25 plus points Yoki J plus assists and
uh John Morant 30 plus points
Booyah there it is hey
that's it we're done let's get up out of
here because we gotta go watch some
games we gotta go win some money so my
name is Greg Ivory next to me is MB but
uh you might call it Michael Bowen and
next to him is Ryan but here on this
show we call him producer Ryan
we are out peace
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]